[Musik]
auch die generation der achtundsechziger
ist langsam aber sicher mit dem
altwerden konfrontiert der schweizer
journalist und autor willi bott
einstiger aktivist und funktionär einer
maoistischen kleinstpartei schreibt in
seinem feinen neuen roman über die
haltbarkeit von hoffnungen und von
idealen ein sprichwort sagt im garten da
nix mehr als mann ausgesehen hat und
manchmal blut das in rungen auf an
vergessen geglaubte zeiten
[Musik]
1979 überfall auf die schweizerische
volkswagen die rote armee fraktion
bringt terror nach zirkus
eine passantin stirn einer der männer
hat vorher noch auf die verfolger
geschoss will gleichmäßig auf dem grat
damit fängt an im roman die aktion vor
der roten armee fraktion in sexy
berufsrecht und wurde bis zuletzt
erklärt ich vor allem klar unter
umständen schweizer beteiligt sind zu
helfen und das wird auch in denen kann
man sagen tabuisiert viva trend der
überzeugte altachtundsechziger hält
rückschau auf seine generation mit
nachdruck beschwört den geist der
rebellion mit fingerspitzen spürt eher
zwiespältiges auf im biotop
schrebergarten lässt er seine figuren im
dreck wie ernst und ließ neuerdings
nachbarn kultivieren einen friedfertigen
lebensabend in den 80ern waren die
erzürnte gegner der polizist im zürcher
langstrassenquartier fleißig als
schnüffler und fischen füller sie die
fotografen und freiheitsliebende alt
68er in die in den 80ern mit störte es
wäre die aufgabe unserer generation
gewesen zu verhindern dass die welt noch
fauliger wird als wir sie angetroffen
haben
nein
[Musik]
total spannend wo man solche
experimentiertag war ich mir eigentlich
auch dass das durch wenn er das
bekenntnis von acht gericht zudem gleich
fast heimlich rührend nordring die
annäherung zwischen linz und ernst doch
die wilde lips hütet ein geheimnis und
der alte schnüffler kommt ihr auf die
schliche streckt seine fühler aus beim
polizei stammtisch im griff
ich bereue nichts erklärt sie 40 nicht
einmal dass sich die kapitalisten gehabt
habe es gibt eine gewalt die fortschritt
bringt der autor provoziert lässt litt
hadern mit der frage wie radikal protest
sein muss um die welt zu ändern gerichte
szene selbe richtung schafft aber
zwischen kita bummi norm einig noch
dafür ein buch behandelt wird die ludwig
im dreck zieht ihn von der terrorszene
aber doch irgendwie sympathisierten mit
was die terrorszene macht das eigene
verhältnis zur gewalt krieg die
klammheimliche freude an dem was
terroristen machten darüber reden jemand
wenn eine nachricht hat sich dort eine
beherbergt oder oder ihm das hilfsmittel
hat das wird immer noch verwickelt
zum glück bestückt wird train seine
figuren mit altersweisheit sanft und
anarchistisch zugleich und noch etwas
gelingt ihm der roman ist eine herzhafte
liebeserklärung an den rebellischen
greift er ausgeschaltet ist ja dass ich
immer in factory frieden so noch nicht
erlebt wie vor vier jahren arbeit das
auf dem ersten stock zusammengetan hat
es ist ein super typ von orientalischen
alte linkshänder quer betriebenes hells
angels wobei sich aufträge in der
wirtschaft
juni
die jury bildeten heimat aber lustig ist
auf diesem cluster lieben wort
retikulozyten kleinlich aber nicht
passiert ihnen reicht eine aussöhnung
mit der vergangenheit fernkampf schwarz
weiße schicht schreit
[Musik]